le défi de ce nouveau gouvernement c'est
le même défi que l'ancien gouvernement
c'est-à-dire de contrôler les dépenses
l'objectif du nouveau gouvernement
couillard et de son ministre des
finances carlos leitao
c'est de croire de faire croître les
dépenses de seulement 1,9 pour cent en
2014 2015 dont croissance consolidée de
seulement 1,9 pour cent ce sera pas
facile à atteindre pour y arriver on
demande des mesures d'économie dans le
secteur de la santé et on demande aux
médecins d'étaler également sur
plusieurs années n'y a pas d'entente
encore mais d'étaler sûr plusieurs
années la hausse de rémunération qui est
prévu dans son budget cette année 285
millions au lieu de 540 millions
d'augmentation pour les médecins le
déficit sera plus important que ce que
monsieur marceau avait annoncé au mois
de février déficit pour 2014-2015 de 2
milliards 350 millions de dollars
il ya beaucoup de mesures d'austérité
jusqu'à un certain point puisque treize
ministères sur 22 devront procéder à des
compressions budgétaires l'environnement
seulement baisse baisse des budgets
prévus de 19 % ce qui est quand même
considérable le gouvernement en fait le
parti libéral avait annoncé en campagne
électorale qu'ils voulaient injecter 15
milliards de dollars de plus dans les
infrastructures au cours des dix
prochaines années
avec ce 15 milliards est annulée on
n'ira pas de l'avant avec cette promesse
on augmente les taxes sur le vin sur la
bière et sur les spiritueux
on coupe de façon horizontale tous les
crédits d'impôt de 20% sans analyse à
savoir si un crédit d'impôt est meilleur
qu'un autre on va faire une analyse avec
la commission sur la fiscalité et la
commission de révision des programmes
mais tout de suite on coupe 20% dans ces
crédits d'impôt et on baisse les impôts
également des pme manufacturières
le taux d'imposition de ces petites et
moyennes entreprises va passer de 8 à 4%
et pour ce qui est des citoyens les
30000 places en garderie qui était prévu
jusqu'en 2018 sont reportés jusqu'en
2022 et la réduction de la taxe sur la
santé est repoussée d'un an ce sera à
partir de 2017 voilà pour ce premier
budget l'état
là